une stratégie qui peinait à convaincre
il y a encore quelques mois
et pourtant aujourd'hui plus de 11
millions de britanniques ont reçu leurs
deux doses de vaccin contre le colis 19
à titre de comparaison en france seuls
deux millions de personnes sont
vaccinées à ce jour un retournement de
situation surprenant puisqu'il y a un an
le royaume uni était pointée du doigt
pour sa tendance à minimiser les risques
du virus
le premier ministre boris johnson avait
même annoncé compter sur l'immunité
collective
d'après le conseil scientifique
britannique il fallait attendre que 60 %
de la population soit infecté par le
virus
nous nous basons sur la science et nous
ferons ce qu'il faut au bon moment nous
ne fermons pas je le répète nous ne
fermons pas les écoles maintenant à
contre courant le royaume uni ne
souhaite alors pas imposer de mesures
sanitaires strictes à sa population
pour le gouvernement et le conseil
scientifique il était trop tôt et des
restrictions aurait été
contre-productive il semble futile de
dire rester chez vous si vous avez des
symptômes mineurs attendait de le faire
quelques jours plus tard sous la
pression de l'épidémie qui progresse
boris johnson annonce la fermeture des
écoles
il faudra attendre le 24 mars 2020 pour
qu un confinement se met en place au
royaume uni pour une durée de trois
semaines durant cette pandémie le
royaume uni affiche un bilan humain
particulièrement lourd ce qui le place
parmi les pays les plus endeuillé
d'europe
alors comment expliquer ce retournement
de situation outre-manche
contre toute attente il pourrait s'agir
du prg excite si vous vouliez une seule
démonstration de l'importance du bric
site vous l'avez si nous étions encore
dans l'ue eux certaines personnes
seraient mortes alors qu'elles ne le
sont pas il n'y a pas de quoi se vanter
c'est tout simplement vrai avec son plan
de vaccination massif londres semble
avoir gagné une première bataille dans
l'après breakes site
le royaume uni s'est assuré une longueur
d'avancé sur la campagne vaccinale
en investissant dès cet été directement
auprès des laboratoires pfizer
astrazeneca
éval neva en comparaison l'union
européenne a attendu le mois de novembre
un programme qui semble aujourd'hui
avoir porté ses fruits et autres manches
fort de sa stratégie vaccinale boris
johnson a annoncé la réouverture des
bars et restaurants d'ici avril
l'objectif du gouvernement britannique
reste inchangée assuré une première dose
de vaccin à chaque adulte avant la fin
du mois de juillet